how pissed were you and justin hartley
played aquaman in the spin-off and you
didn't
cause you were aquaman on [ __ ]
smallville with me yeah that's right no
i wasn't mad at all why would i be mad
well because you know like why didn't
they consider you well they did but they
uh
people don't know you know what i went
through with that but
you know i didn't i hadn't done anything
at the time i didn't i hadn't seen
marvel was your first is it my first gig
first gig like you seeing you on a set
you know making jokes and whatever i was
like god he's so relaxed you know like
you're the first thing i ever saw yeah
you're like you're my mom basically i'm
like a little dinosaur coming out of the
shell let's see you first son yeah
yeah because it was your first role it
was my first thing i first got a
speaking role i was so overwhelmed i was
like how many people are so many people
on this set
i never knew that was your first role i
never knew until i read about it but i
remember on set i was like he's just
great he did a great job
i've always been good at faking it you
know you were faking it oh wow yeah i
didn't know what i was doing and so the
you know the i i was told that the
episode that i i was on season five the
first one that i came on it was a
well-oiled machine at that point
it was uh
it was like a ratings record that
episode you know which was like
astounding having been on for that like
it did really well apparently so they
wanted to greenlight a spin-off and they
were like congratulations and i was
getting calls from people the studio
like i'm the guy
who's just here to make sure you keep
your head on the ground so you call me
day or night if you're in trouble i'm
like you know i was like
oh yeah these people were like prepping
me for like the biggest show on tv i'm
like okay and we start working on a deal
and at the time upn and warner brothers
had merged to create the cw and the
president of the upn had taken over and
he's looking at this roster of shows
the slate and going uh who the hell's
that guy
which is the same thing i would do i
mean i was sitting there going like i
can't believe it was this easy i've been
here three weeks i got my own show
oh my gosh so they just he just axed it
next it actually goes
he can't be he can't have his own show
and so they called me they're like we're
trying to fight him on it because we
looked for so long and we love you
but he doesn't want you to do this we
have to go back and find people but
maybe we won't find anybody and they did
they didn't they went back and they
didn't find anybody and so they came
back again and they're like so he said
fine he'll give it a shot you know we'll
do the pilot together and i was like
great okay great i can get my own show
you know i'm sitting cool
but you know but again like like with
reacher there's this asterisk by for me
where i'm like i guess i'm not really
wanted but maybe i'll run with it as you
know
so it's like it had been taken from me
and then like a week later they were
like actually
justin hartley just came off passions
and uh he's available and we're gonna go
with justin hartley and i was like i
don't know who that is but great you
know good for you and uh and i
i learned the best lesson i could
early on to hold loosely to this stuff
because nothing is guaranteed and
nothing's owed to me and if i hadn't
learned that lesson early i would have
been an entitled [ __ ] um i probably
still am but a much greater degrees
um you know so uh it taught me to hold
you know told real loosely to this stuff
and i think it's a great lesson to have
right out of the gate so i'm grateful
that i didn't get in and i also you know
if i would have gotten that show i never
would have learned really learned the
craft or studied myself
i would have just
floated on whatever shows that gate you
know that would have had some ancillary
you're gonna get this movie because you
were on that show
and um
i've had a very different experience
where i've had to like
really
uh you know
find my voice you know